Sous-titres par Milan Lefort.
Bonjour à tous. Aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic : Le Son.
Imaginons deux billes reliées par un ressort.
Si l'on s'amuse à déplacer l'une des deux billes, on va étirer et contracter le ressort.
Ce qui va avoir pour effet de déplacer la deuxième bille.
Dans notre univers, tous les objets sont composés, à l'échelle microscopique, d'atomes.
Il se trouve que les atomes qui composent un objet interagissent entre eux
un peu de la même façon que les deux billes qu'on avait reliées par un ressort.
Deux atomes se repoussent si on essaye de les rapprocher,
et s'attirent si on essaye de les séparer.
Au sein d'un matériau comme de l'eau, de l'air ou encore de la roche,
les atomes sont répartis de façon relativement régulière.
Imaginons que l'on puisse déplacer certains de ces atomes.
Par exemple, les atomes qui se trouvent à gauche.
En les déplaçant, on les a rapprochés des atomes suivants.
Comme dans le cas des deux billes qu'on avait reliées par un ressort,
ils vont donc repousser les atomes qui se trouvent à leur droite.
Et, au cours du temps, ce mouvement va se répercuter tout au long du matériau.
La perturbation qu'on a infligée au début s'est ainsi propagée dans l'espace d'atome en atome.
C'est cette propagation qu'on appelle une "onde sonore".
En fonction du type de matériau, les ondes sonores vont se propager plus ou moins vite.
Par exemple, dans l'eau, les atomes sont plus proches les uns des autres que dans l'air.
Lorsqu'on émet une perturbation, elle va donc avoir plus de faciliter à se propager dans l'eau,
car les atomes y sont plus proches.
Ainsi, ils se communiquent leur déplacement plus facilement.
Si on effectue l'expérience pour comparer, on observe que la perturbation se propage
quatre fois plus rapidement dans l'eau que dans l'air.
Notre planète est entourée d'une atmosphère composée d'air.
C'est-à-dire que tout ce qui se trouve en surface est constamment entouré d'une multitude d'atomes.
Sur Terre, beaucoup d'objets et d'êtres vivants génèrent des vibrations.
On peut par exemple penser aux ailes d'une abeille, au moteur d'une voiture, ou encore aux cordes d'une guitare.
En vibrant de la sorte, un tel objet génère une perturbation régulière
qui va se propager dans l'air en faisant vibrer ses atomes, les uns après les autres.
Pour pouvoir détecter ces vibrations, notre corps humain dispose de deux oreilles.
Lorsque la perturbation se propage jusqu'à notre oreille, l'air qui vibre à l'intérieur
va entrainer dans son mouvement, une petite membrane qu'on appelle "le tympan".
A partir du tympan, l'oreille va alors générer un signal électrique
qui va être envoyé jusqu'au cerveau pour lui communiquer l'information.
Enfin, le cerveau va créer une sensation à partir de ce signal.
C'est cette sensation qu'on appelle le "son".
Et c'est ce qui nous permet d'entendre au quotidien les vibrations des objets qui nous entourent, à distance.
En fonction du type de vibrations, notre cerveau va créer des sensations différentes.
D'une part, plus la vibration est puissante, c'est-à-dire que les atomes vibrent avec une plus grande amplitude,
plus le volume du son que l'on ressent va être élevé.
Si le volume devient trop élevé, il peut même devenir dangereux pour l'oreille.
D'autre part, plus la vibration va être rapide, plus le son que l'on perçoit va être aigu.
Ainsi, une lente vibration va être perçue comme un son grave.
Alors qu'une vibration rapide va être perçue comme un son aigu.
Nos oreilles nous permettent ainsi de détecter la vibration des objets qui nous entourent.
Mais cependant, elles ne nous permettent pas de capter tous les sons.
En particulier, l'oreille humaine n'est sensible qu'aux ondes sonores qui vibrent entre vingt et vingt mille fois par seconde.
Ce qui veut dire qu'il est impossible pour nous d'entendre un objet qui vibre moins que vingt fois par seconde.
C'est que l'on appelle un "infrason".
Et à l'inverse, il nous est également impossible d'entendre un objet qui vibre plus de vingt mille fois par seconde.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un "ultrason".
Cela dit, on trouve dans la nature d'autres animaux qui possèdent des oreilles plus performantes que les nôtres.
Ces animaux peuvent ainsi détecter et utiliser des gammes de sons qui nous sont imperceptibles.
C'est par exemple le cas de certains cétacés, comme les dauphins,
qui utilisent des ultrasons afin de communiquer et de percevoir leur environnement.
Enfin, les ondes sonores peuvent de propager dans tous les matériaux car ceux-ci sont composés d'atomes.
Mais dans le vide, c'est-à-dire en l'absence de matière et donc d'atomes,
les vibrations d'un objet ne peuvent pas se propager car, pour se faire,
il faudrait que leur mouvement puisse se transmettre de proche en proche.
Les ondes sonores ne peuvent donc pas se propager dans le vide,
et c'est pour cette raison qu'il n'y a pas de son dans l'espace.